Americans are locked and loaded like
never before gun ownership is exploding
across the country as crime rages in
Democrat L cities more than half of
Voters say they or someone in their
household owns a gun that's a record
high and it shows over the weekend a Los
Angeles homeowner shot and killed a
suspected burglar after a group of men
wearing dark hoodies and masks broke
into his home and just last month
another Los Angeles homeowner getting
into a shootout with a pair of thugs who
tried to break into his home forcing the
robbers to flee empty-handed and
hundreds of Bodega owners in Democrat L
New York City are now arming themselves
with guns as violent thieves plague
their businesses listen to this anyone
that's out there looking to uh Rob
us hurt us kill us beware you may be
walking into the wrong Bodega because
now we have the same P Firepower you
have good for Fernando matelo who was an
old friend of mine but you know Harold
you know not only do a record number of
Americans now have guns but a record
number of Democrats are uh have have
guns and gun permits so if the liberal
voters don't feel safe why do they keep
electing the same softon crime policies
that some of the Democrats are bringing
with them so most of the people I know
own guns are Democrats
um so I don't look at this as a a
Democrat Republican thing I think we
look at it that way at times because
Democrats um argue more forcefully and
loudly for uh some reforms and some
restrictions may be the wrong word but
some background some some some
conditions on who can own guns um and I
think that is I think that is right I
mean more than three to one Americans
believe there are to be firmer
background checks stricter background
checks for that two as long as people
are in compliance with the law uh I I I
applaud I'm like you and I think we were
around the table some reaction as we
watched to Bodega owner here in New York
uh I have no not only do I not have an
issue with that I support that uh I
would hope that someone uh who is able
to own a gun and seeks to own a gun to
protect his or her home they have every
right to do that um my only I think we
shouldn't confuse the fact that I think
we sometimes like to talk about the
politics and the demographics around
crime I mean I don't I don't say that
that high that the highest murder rates
are in red States so there's something
wrong that that almost implies that
Democrats don't hold on one second it
almost implies that Democrats don't care
about Republicans uh being killed and
when we talk about blue Leed cities or
the ones with the highest crime and
murder rates as if we're saying
Republicans don't care about Democrats I
know that's not the case my only point
is I I think we got to be more serious
about real answers and where there are
shortcomings on the parts of any
politician they should be blamed you as
me a specific question I'll answer I
have said on this show those Das who
were for cashless Bell who are not
enforcing the law I would hope that
people would unelect them in in the
jurisdictions that they're in and I
would hope that to the extent they can
recall them they would begin that
process but before they do that anyone
that's in compliance with gun ownership
should be able to own a gun and protect
his or her home or his or her business
Dana it's not about the Das it's about
the legislation that we have and the
state legislators who have decided in
every state that cashless bail is the
answer it's not about the da setting the
bail or not setting it but is is it true
that it's the Democrats and the Democrat
Le cities where we've got these issues
where crime is running rampant not just
because of the Das but because of the
structure of the law in the jurisdiction
well one of the things and I think we
just talked about it last week about the
shoplifting laws that says that you
could shoplift every day $950 a day and
under then you don't get prosecuted so
of course that's what's going to happen
and the violence is increasing partly
because defund the police which was a
liberal policy worked very well and
there are police shortages all across
America there are problems of response
times and so people are saying okay well
then I have to be able to protect myself
the largest increase of people buying
guns right now are actually Jewish
people because they are highly concerned
they're learning how to use uh we
weapons in order to protect themselves
and some of these liberal cities they
don't realize that their policies
increased gun ownership and then they
wonder why they can't get gun control
ped there's actually reason for that is
a circular problem and you know Jesse
the the the issue of um gun control and
American feeling as Dana is talking
about 911 doesn't get there in time
there's not enough police to get there
in time so in Los Angeles we've got two
people who have used deadly physical
Force against Intruders one was taken in
into the police station in Los Angeles
in handcuffs today I don't know why and
another one had his pistol permit taken
away apparently cuz he yelled at the
Sheriff's Department for showing up 3
days late yeah citizens should not be
the first line of defense we should be
the last line of defense we will be the
first line of defense if we have to but
it shouldn't be like that the government
should be protecting us and I wish the
government especially Joe Biden would
try to protect us the way he did from
covid instead for Crime because a lot of
these people out there are buying guns
for the first time which I think is a
good thing judge when you buy your first
gun it enhances your
citizenship I can't really put it into
words but it makes you more responsible
it makes you more self-aware more mature
and I'm I know a lot of Democrats voted
for Joe Biden they're buying their first
weapon I know Republicans buying their
first weapon and this guy out here he's
in California they have a high
magazine limit over there you can only
have 10 rounds in the clip judge ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals just upheld
that ban there were three to four armed
men in his house and he only has 10
Rounds he's lucky Y and he was
protecting his grandmother he's now
favorite grandson of all time but this
is the worst feeling at 5:00 in the
morning and you there's armed Intruders
at your house with a toddler and your
grandmother and they took him out in
cuffs all right wrap it up Greg yeah if
they have like a good neighbor of the
Year award they they should start one
for that guy I want I I want all my
neighbor neighbors armed you know
because what he did was he just made his
neighborhood safer cuz that neighborhood
had been plagued by uh home Invaders and
he introduced or reintroduced the idea
of risk to Crime because we've removed
that through these rules and these G and
stuff they thought they could do it and
he just killed one of them and that just
told that was a clear message and we we
did talk about we predicted this that
law- abiding people would take the law
into their own hands if they realized
that police hands were already tied and
that's what happens you know I don't
want to go to jail you know I'm too
delicate I wouldn't last but if I was
faced with having to shoot and kill
somebody in my house I would definitely
do it and because you know you have
that's you know that's just you know
self-defense is an inherent part of
being a human being so the idea you just
have to you just have to do that if you
feel that no one else is there
especially if your family is there uh
and maybe we'll end up with prisons
filled with really good people and the
streets are filled with really bad
people but you know it's weird I think
about the a block this topic has a lot
in top in common with the a block this
denial of potential rights is based on
the fact that we are seen as the guilty
party it's the oppressor the oppressor
versus oppressed lens we can't have we
cannot have weapons the criminal has
more rights because you know the
internal stain of our lineage makes it
impossible for us to defend ourselves
yeah but you know it is a natural right
though the ability to defend yourself
and there are less lethal guns out there
that don't kill but in any event up next
is technology about to ruin concerts
rock legend band KISS is going virtual
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else